avec quel animateur aimeriez vous passer
la nuit vous matthieu delormeau vous
avez choisi qui s'est choisi au pas il a
perdu une dent dans le grain alors oui
alors je recommence j'ai choisi ophélie
meunier aa du tube du tube you tube et
bah alors il n'a pas choisi la plus
moche non non non j'aimerais bien
découvrir
je peux vous dire que franchement je
trouve c'est la fille la plus jolie
actuellement à la télévision mais c'est
une bombe
total est franchement si ça l'amusé je
ne serait ce qu'une fois mais je
reconnais que coucher avec quelque chose
qui me bat base est passé une nuit c'est
pour faire comme si je peux me permettre
je ne vous comprends plus non mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ophélie meunier vous vous êtes d'accord
j'ambitionne mer à oui si on a un gros
tube parce que j'ai une verdez elle est
un peu froide
je pense qu'effectivement il faut la
modeler un peu discuté avec l entrée
dans sa tête pour comprendre qu'elle est
vraiment ça mon avis là là vous lui
faites ça l'a appelé la police depuis
cinq minutes déjà
à la fin le 17 la mode oui fait les
meuniers is a way les super mignonne
n'allais pas très froide c'est pas vrai
on doit croiser allées froides à
l'extérieur méchant l'intérieur après la
casse
[Rires]
clio alors on attend là à aller dit guy
lagache et vous venez dans la chaîne
ben oui c'est pas parce qu'il est dans
la chaîne chercher c'est la mèche blonde
c'est faux ce côté premier de la classe
qui je pense est très sauvage en règle
ah ouais alors quand je les ai vus
sachez le il est sauvage voilà non c'est
à dire qu'il n'est pas du coin peel
autres alors je me dis que j'ai vu un
oui mais il n'est pas dans les locaux
non non ça va maintenant il est ou non
une femme et tout le monde a une femme
faut arrêter avec ça est ce qu'elle est
mais ça va arrêter d'être 2015 sans
déconner vivez avec votre canon peuvent
être rencontrés çà veut dire guy lagache
bien pouvoir dans les couloirs de des
beats et vous dis je vous emmène en week
end
voilà même à rungis vous y allez non non
je vais cueillir des fraises avec lui
mais où enfin oui oui pourquoi pas oui
mais non mais moi aussi j'ai quelqu'un
mais je devais répondre alors j'ai
répondu alors mais là alors je vous dire
ici
mais oui ici quand on est dans cette
émission plus personne à personne il
faut partir avez-vous aussi les amis de
personnes arrêtées
jean michel mr e je les adore il est un
art mais qu'est-ce que je me fous de
votre avis sur guy lagache
bien sûr on vous dit tout non non on va
pas on lance tout de suite le hashtag
rôle ou 12 mois ses clio sada et bientôt
à 20 ans vous rigolez moi c'est vous ça
peut aller même par chaque sas et
mercedes gilles verdez sophie davant ah
oui je la sens bien la davar wii 2
cérébraux correctement la pâleur en
tunisie sophie davant ah oui sophy
diarra sera ça veut dire qu'il ya très
longtemps là il ya deux personnes qui
ont compris cette vague maison qui fait
quand je pense qu'on aurait des choses à
se dire au bout de la nuit et brouillard
soir photo quand même un petit peu oui
oui oui mais bon non mais c'est
quelqu'un de très bien et je pense que
voilà on pourrait se raconter des
histoires allaient l'un vers l'autre
frère un papa forcément se toucher tout
de suite
au bout d'un certain temps quoi voilà on
est deux êtres qui finalement ça tire
après des débuts difficiles
d'accord on va quand même pas le sexe
qua non d'une nuit et vous sophie davant
way ah non pas trop non
non parce qu'on peut attendre au moins
un mois alors bon choix si valérie
damidot mais par contre il faudra pas
qu'on soit sur un lit superposé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
valérie que j'adore il sauva bien elle a
une ça on va dormir aura sera toute la
lumière comme ça je l'abats ruf ledesma
d'une je comprends mais elle est sexy
elle est sexy valérie je suis d'accord
je suis d'accord
jean-luc guilaine chenu et françoise
joly vous avez sur des pressions n'ont
envoyé spécial parce que je pense que
ils ont besoin de réconfort en ce moment
là mais dans la mission s'arrête et je
pense qu'elles ont du temps et puis 2,6
et bien comme celle là d'autres chômeurs
et mission s'arrête vous auriez dû
prendre julien lepers oh je sais pas
pourquoi je me sentais mois